foreign
Ethan joins us up next in Madison
Wisconsin Ethan welcome to the show
hi thanks how's it going doing great how
are you what's going on
good uh so I graduated in May of 2021
last year and uh over that course of
time I paid off twenty thousand dollars
in student loans I just took the first
job I could get out of school and
hustled and grinded and did that and
then I come to find out the student loan
forgiveness thing is happening
and I found that I'm eligible to apply
to like get my money back so to speak
I'd have to go back into debt with my
loan provider and then have my debt
forgiven that way
um how should I go about that should I
do that go back into debt in order to be
forgiven uh is that wise okay
all right I gotta jump in George sure
quick uh because I read entirely too
much news every day there are now
multiple lawsuits that have been filed
by multiple States
against President Biden's executive
action this is not it's not me making
this up this is happening the reason is
is because you have a lot of privately
held student loans and so when he made
that executive action to say we're going
to pay off we're going to forgive ten
thousand it's affecting and again I'm
not I'm not defending it I'm just saying
it's real money that's that's that's
hurting private companies that hold
loans and people sign up for and then
the states are motivated to protect
those companies because those companies
are tax paying companies in their state
so I don't know if you're paying
attention to the news Ethan but that has
happened and so you have two things
going on so the lawsuits have been filed
so the ten thousand dollar forgiveness
is not happening until those lawsuits
are all dealt with number one number two
there there's they're they're not
actively moving towards those refunds
right now anyway so I I just want to put
that out there George because people
feel like this is a done deal I'm going
to go ahead and move forward with this
and then it's the basis of his question
so I don't think it's going to happen
yeah and for those listening that aren't
clear on how this is working because
Ethan's gone well they're going to put
me back into debt but it's forgiveness
so what we've been seeing is the student
loan companies are saying all right
we're going to drop 10 grand back into
your bank account but we are also
reinstating your debt balance to ten
thousand dollars and now the hope is
down the line at some point the
government comes in wipes that ten
thousand balance it makes my head hurt
only the government can come up with
something that's stupid pretty
convoluted but that's how it's working
right Ethan am I right on that
uh yeah that's what you described sounds
great to me so no no don't do it so
here's what here's what some people are
doing I'm not going to advocate for
against this but what they're doing is
saying hey I'm gonna take that ten
thousand dollars in the bank and make
sure not to spend it which that takes a
level of discipline alone for people who
had already gone into debt uh thinking
that this was a good idea and then
they're saying I'm gonna hang on to the
10 000 in case they don't forgive it and
I'll still have the money to pay it off
Ken oh sure that sounds wonderful
so Ethan that's kind of what you're
describing as a if you go through with
this that's what the hope is is that you
hang on to the 10 000 and once it's
forgiven you go all right cool this
money is free and clear now
gotcha gotcha so there's risk involved
is what we're saying and unnecessary
risks so don't do it
pay your student loans off the
government is not going to do it for you
and you're completely debt free now
yeah that's correct
so but he's saying I can get the refund
oh I see forgiveness yeah yeah what baby
step are you on now
um I was in four five and six but I just
replaced the transmission my car sent
back on three restocking that emergency
fund good man nice well you know what's
clear to me is that the secret sauce to
winning with money is Ethan and not a
third party not a government not a
forgiveness program and so I'm sticking
with the Ethan program for now and if
you so choose to do it I'm not mad at
you I'm happy for you for it to you know
Propel your financial Journey but
there's a lot of risk and a lot of
unknowns right now yeah certainly just
wait wait until the dust settles in the
form of all these lawsuits yeah I
appreciate the call